Let's answer a few other questions about these algorithms--alpha, beta and gamma.
First, I want you to tell me whether the best-case running time for given input size
is always no longer than the best measured time for each algorithm--true or false.
Also, I'd like you to tell me whether the worst-case running time for given input size
is at least the worst measured time for each algorithm.
I also like to know whether algorithm beta is the fastest for all inputs, not just 100, 200,
300 and 400 but any input I get that is algorithm beta faster always than alpha and gamma.
And finally, I'd like to know whether the small inputs the algorithm with exponential behavior
is sometimes faster than the algorithm with polynomial behavior.
So tell me which of these statements are true and which are false.